okay jamie danielle so nice to see you
um the tourist is the kind of show that
from the first five minutes you're
hooked and the biggest tease of my life
is only getting one episode so
now i have to patiently wait to see who
is trying to kill you jamie um how was
what was your reaction when you were
reading this script
uh my reaction was who is trying to kill
me
you know it is a very entertaining
six hours um uh when i i you know i
signed on to it based on three
episodes i think maybe four maybe four
um
and uh it's harry and jack williams
created this
sort of genre bending world you know
that really keeps you guessing and you
think you have a
a pretty solid take on where it's going
to go and then something really truly
insane happens and you're sort of
blindsided by by some other character
and you're off on a totally different
content to where you thought you're
headed so i think it's going to keep
people guessing and hopefully hopefully
keep people entertained
how intense was shooting that opening
scene with the truck like how involved
were you with all of that yeah a lot
yeah we we you know they were very they
really wanted that to be a really strong
visual opening and dramatic opening and
i think they've succeeded in that um
there's obviously influences steven
spielberg's jewel i don't think anyone
will mind me saying that's quite a clear
reference and inspiration for it um but
so they took a lot of time with it you
know we did have time with it and it was
it was tough and uh i uh i i'm up for
doing as much of that as i can until
they won't let me anymore basically and
you know obviously if it's a big drone
shot and the the cars this size and the
screen that's not me driving obviously
but um
you know for the most part you know i
was getting darn dirty with it and um
yeah i think it looks great i mean they
were still you know we still towards the
end of the shoot were coming back to
shoot more angles of it and stuff yeah
it was they put a lot into it
it was so well done danielle love your
character so much both of your
characters are so different but they
come together in this very unusual
circumstance what do you like about the
dynamic between these two characters
honestly it was really fun to just kind
of get to explore together because
i mean he doesn't know who he is
and
she's kind of like stuck in this world
and has like a very specific you know
view of the world which is very positive
and
lots of light and um kind of seeing
that meld i feel like helen's very
different from all the other characters
in the series and so
kind of seeing her interact with that
world was really fun um and it's such a
different dynamic than
the relationship that jamie's character
has with all the other characters so
it's i don't know just like creates
balance like like jamie was saying it's
very genre-bending you never really know
what's going to be a comedic scene
what's going to be a dramatic scene both
thriller scary like it just kind of
all happens and it's all a surprise it's
just
it was a surprise to us to put it that
way
oh i love that
well jamie considering your character
has amnesia i'm sure there's moments in
all of our lives that we wish we could
forget but do you guys have an audition
that you wish you could just completely
forget you ever did
every single one that i ever did
really
yeah true i mean i was i'm
without i'm very lucky i haven't had to
do it for a long time and i
i'm so glad because
uh it's a brutal brutal experience and
it's for me nothing like what acting is
you know obviously it's acting but it's
nothing like what making film and
television is um but i don't really know
how they should change that but yeah no
i i've walked out of a couple like truly
like stopped uh and said i'm wasting all
of your time i'm so sorry i just left
the room but i did that two or three
times in my life
oh my gosh
look on big projects or just sometimes
yep yep
[Laughter]
not going to name names that's fine
daniel how about you
uh you know what i can't even remember
what it's for but i remember kind of
when i first came out here going in for
something i walked in the room and
they didn't look at me once not the
entire time it was really funny and i
was like there is no point in me being
here right now like it was just really
quite comical more than anything else
they looked at me walking the room and
then they did not look at me once more
the entire audition and i left i was
just like yeah i don't think um they'll
ever have me back in that room that's
okay like i'm okay to not have that
experience again that was it yes
that's good to forget that
yeah it's not yourself
experience
it wasn't the best you know sometimes
you have really really lovely people
really caring but like jamie said
what you're doing in an audition room is
not what you're doing on set like it's a
very different experience some people
are really good auditioners
and then being on set is very foreign
some people are really good being on set
and don't know how to audition and it's
like they're two different things they
really are so it never quite feels
balanced yeah well glad that stage
behind you congrats on the show
okay
jamie i'm now dying to know what what
audition you walked out of
[Laughter]
maybe one day i'll be revealed if i do
one of these press days drunk maybe i'll
tell you
okay just wait and tell et canada morgan
hoffman right here um guys thanks so
much really appreciate it thanks morgan
you